e aí galera se chama ronaldo bom gosto e
os tempos tem pra quem não sabe é você
espanhol é para o impulso é um olho em
cultura galera está abordando o assunto
hoje muito muito polêmico mas não faço
essa piada não é muito mas é verdade
melhor futebol de gosto musical a cor
que quer a pessoa não tem gente que fala
assim eu não goste bonita eu não gosto
de anita eu gosto é então revelou só se
você for uma balada não vai estar
tocando caetano veloso na balada então a
música tem as pessoas que são o próprio
para cada música tocada música tem
públicos para cada música tem porque
ficar fora mal do estilo que o outro
lote por exemplo rock né
você tá aqui escutando rock né
[Música]
ai ai ai
só que a sua mãe passa em escuta você
escutando ao só que ela não escuta desse
jeito ela escuta mais ou menos assim
a gente tem de explicar pra ela que não
é isso uma novinha não vai entrar na
cabeça dele não adianta que não vai
entender nunca agora bota mar batista
cantando pra ela assim o satanás na sala
de cirurgia pela vida silvinha vocês
sofrem por feno ela entender diz assim
um homem chamado batista sabe tocar o
coração da pessoa que a pessoa quando
ela gosta não adianta negócio rapaz west
china por muito tempo a falar é de chera
é fera e banda a música de axé como um
rapaz atual tem as pessoas antigas não
conhece eu digo chega pra minha mãe fala
assim voz era a senhora sabe o action
disse eu sei lá quem é cheia público
pode chegar até o carro da mãe dele e
falei vou pela bonita e eu conto estilo
que demorei muito a entender é o rap
repente um negócio aqui no nordeste é
que os cara perguntou foi pra você faz
um não acordo com você eu vou fazer um
repente pra vocês que o youtube trabalho
do mundo é pequeno mas só aceitará ea
rigidez do pará
depois vejo o vídeo dos carajás valeu ao
canalha aí é fraco não só assistir nesta
letra depois de cair na via fazendo
coisas e caneta e depois que ela sai de
noites a droga tinha na casa da amiga
piddac saudade
[Música]
nós do nariz mas greve agir no mercado
títulos esperei mais é que você não
gostou e empregado é e banda de forró
pagode forró é muito engraçado a começar
porque a banda antigamente eu acho que
vai entrar na banda de forró chamado
conta deixar o cabelo crescer bem muito
e ficava que voltou em cima do palco
cantando com cabelo ar livre do que o da
mãe que estava assistindo a outra
cláusula está no contato era cantar bem
fininho cinzinha até estourar os
tímpanos de cantar o rio porque além de
ter o cabelo males do que o da mãe que
estava assistindo ele também tinha voz
mais firme do que é ruim é que estava
desistindo
[Música]
eu não consigo mais de mim eu não
consigo te esquecer de mim porque o
abate está aqui ea outra pico com vocês
e aí chegou o que eu acho que ele canta
tão fino que nem ele mesmo a mãe ea avó
dele o que ele faz e não apela pra
galera está andando na linha lindo ele
fala quer ouvir você mas na verdade ele
queria falar isso aqui e vinha falando
em música vai ter um show do joão é
pioneira em fortaleza um show só de
música com banda e tudo bateria guitarra
baixo vai ser [ __ ] e por ser um show sem
um show de humor que eu sempre faço um
show só de música engraçada bem
baratinho lá na loja romeu no shopping
via sul vai ser o dia 4 de julho no
centro de eventos do sebrae ce quer
saber tudo sobre esse show é só clicar
no primeiro link na descrição do vídeo
vamos lá que o show vai ser [ __ ]
mas são coisas engraçadas que eu queria
passar para vocês não saibam gente não
importa o que o coleguinha da escuta não
é gosto de deixar de escutar
assim como você pode ouvir uma coisa que
só a mim não gosta taxa vai deixar você
escuta também então é isso aí se você
tiver título de cidadã falou então isso
aí você vai se divertir do que você faz
se clica em gostei no facebook marca um
amigo seu para assistir esse vídeo no
twitter da itc me ajuda muito e se
inscreve no canal nunca perdeu em ouvir
beleza
muito obrigado a tsx que até aqui e